papa non nous étions 15 heures que cette
attaque
j'aimerais piloter le bateau un jour et
pour rêver ou du bois au royaume du roi
pelé pourrait trouver maman yoann c'est
impossible
booth pas paris
[Musique]
là
le royaume du roi plume et un endroit
terrifiant avec des lois très dur [ __ ]
tu dois repartir immédiatement celle qui
habite
il faut que tu te rendes compte que ta
présence ici est un très grave danger
l'europe lui m'avait apporté ma maman
je voulais qu'elle revienne mais je
savais que ça finirait par le cadastre
tout cela est la faute billboard et
cessent de faible à tout bout de champ
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]